es war halt ich unsere debattenkultur
für verroht mir macht sie sogar
mittlerweile sorge wir haben seit corona
empfinde ich es ganz ganz stark
unglaublich viel hass im netz und
übrigens von beiden lagern also von
denen die für die impfungen sind und von
denen die gegen die impfungen sind aber
die ungeimpften hassen auch die
geimpften und andersrum und es wird sich
beleidigt und ich war ganz in selbst
muss ich sagen das möchte ich gerne mit
ihnen teilen ich habe auf twitter
gelesen von dem islamexperten ahmad
mansour der integrationsexperte ist er
hat getwittert ich bin vieles gewohnt
beleidigung bedrohung auf der straße
angespuckt werden aber dass sie in den
letzten stunden überrascht nicht bilder
von waffen enthauptete menschen und
wünsche meine kinder mögen eine impfung
sterben will ich nicht akzeptieren macht
es gut für mich darf das nicht sein wie
kann man einem mann wünschen dass seine
kinder sterben an der impfung und auch
mir schlägt ihr wurde das nachfüllen
nach acht immer hat entgegen einmal von
den menschen die selber nicht geimpft
sind und mich dafür hassen dass ich
gesund bin und ist auch sage und dann
von denen die den lockdown wollen aber
ich bin gegen den lokal und gegen die
impfpflicht ich würde mir wünschen
aufhören mit dem beleidigungen aufhören
mit dem hass und zwar auf beiden seiten
wir müssen endlich dafür sorgen dass
unsere debattenkultur in deutschland
weniger brot ist bei mir macht das
wirklich angst manchmal
als ich glaube ich wenn alle zustimmen
und applaudieren ja es ist ich glaube es
nicht dass jemand der krieg sprechen
wird bloß diese kultur diese debatten
kultur und diese hetze und dieser hass
in den sozialen medien ist jetzt nicht
neu der ist ja jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen verschärft auch worden wird sie
vielleicht jetzt auch ein bisschen
fokussieren auf die krone debatte aber
wir als politiker oder ich als ehemalige
politiker ich habe das jahre vorher
schon
festgestellt und fest gemerkt auch als
als bei mir war sehr viel im ausland ich
war im iran überall sehr viele berater
in syrien überall unterwegs und
natürlich bin ich im iran bin habe ich
natürlich ein kopftuch auf ist ist klar
so sehr wir gar nicht das land betreten
und kann auch keine converter zudem
südbayern hoffentlich auch entzündungen
man hat immer noch einen punkt
eine kittelschürze damals nein aber ich
habe genauso unter du bekommst du wirst
geköpft du warst geführt hatte was
aufgehängt und
ja und dann überlegst du nicht gehst du
damit um ja das ist so eine geschichte
und die polizei sagt natürlich dann auch
okay er soll man dagegen vorgehen oder
sollen wir nicht dafür vorgehen und ich
habe damals auch nicht dagegen vorgehen
das eine mal das andere mal dann ja
hatte ich auch der polizeischutz
bekommen wie lange hat aber meine kinder
bedroht gehabt dass ihr meine kinder
auch etwas antun ist fast ein halbes
jahr bis ihn gefunden haben
ja auch noch gewesen damals also denn
das haben sie aber kurz rein gefunden
aber am anfang haben und dann diese
zweite mal als das kam und haben auch
gerd niemann ist das vielleicht nicht so
ernst nehmen sollte die leute nicht noch
aufwerten dadurch ja dass das mal in die
und die staatsanwaltschaft wirklich
nicht anzeigen ist ihnen lieber weil
dann können sie diese menschen auch
verfolgen und ich würde heute auch jedem
raten die anzeige zu machen was ich
damals das zweite mal nicht gemacht habe
weil ich weiß auch nicht mehr man soll
auch diese verrückten auch nicht nur so
nach dem den vordergrund stellen aber
heute würde ich jeden sagen anzeigen auf
jeden fall ich glaube in der diagnose
will endlich niemand widersprechen wenn
man sich überlegt was sind die gründe
dann frage ich mich schon was sind
gesellschaftliche veränderungen was sind
politische entscheidungen zu corona zu
flüchtlingen und was man vielleicht auch
technologische entwicklungen also wie
social media funktioniert dass ich meine
wut und hass die algorithmen mögen das
weil das die klicks erhöht also welcher
dieser treiber interagiert da wie das
eine total spannende frage die glaube
ich noch gar nicht richtig geklärt ist
ehrlich gesagt es gab ja ich habe
neulich eine von ihm gesehen wo jemand
die sieben todsünden im parallel
gestellt dazu jeweils zur jeweiligen
internetportalen also ich weiss ich hier
ist an amazon und zorn ist dritter und
und völlerei ist lieferando und ich fand
das fand das sehr witzigen ich muss
sagen ich rate ihm zu bisschen mehr
gelassenheit oder ich rate dazu zu
abstinenz von diesen anti sozialen
medien ich habe mir das längst abgewöhnt
die in die in die kommentarspalten zu
schauen ich habe mir das abgewöhnt tritt
da fand ich ein jahr lang lustig und ins
beschritten ist eng noch lästig und ich
muss sagen denn die samen diesen hass
botschaften auf twitter zu viel
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken ist er
vergleichbar in der vordigitalen welt
als wenn man sich zur wenn man auf eine
öffentliches klo geht an einem bahnhof
und anfängt die die die die kraft die
graffiti zu lesen die die leute damals
war hinterlassen da die mir zu viel
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken finde ich
eigentlich finde ich abwäge ich also ich
lese lieber ein gutes buch als klo
graffiti
die sozialen medien gesagt ja so dass
sie als soziale medien zu bezeichnen ist
ja bisher ist ja auch irre führen das
ist für mich schon mal das zitat der
sendung alle kleine heute von der aber
sebastian gehst du das denn glaubst dass
die korona politik schon die
gesellschaft spaltet und diese
debattenkultur auch hervorbringt diese
verrohung
ja also ich meine krone sind thema das
spaltet viele und natürlich bin ich auch
frustriert wie lange sich das schon hin
zieht und wie
wie manche leute sich da quer stellen
oder oder was passiert im bereich fake
news und und du hast das beispiel von
800 mann gebracht acht mal dass ein
guter freund der sendung war hier häufig
zu gast und auch wenn wir in vielen
punkten uns widersprechen das ist das
ist so jenseitig und sich
persönlich vor einem monat war in der
sendung und habe mich damals für eine
informationskampagne für das boot seien
ausgesprochen also informationskampagne
weil damals wusste man aus den aus
anderen ländern das ist nötig sein wird
und hier in deutschland war praktisch
noch kein thema gewesen da er ein thema
im öffentlichen raum ich habe
4102 kommentare unter diesem video
gehabt und nur hast kein einziges
positives wo ich nur die hass gegen die
alle gelesen dann oder und großteils
also ich hab das muss ja vorsichtig mit
schlagen und auch wenn ihm auf twitter
die debatte es ist es hat sich aber
immer besucht war das geht
auch in brand einige
sind beschleuniger und wenn man sich die
debatten auf twitter anschaut wie
heutzutage ich finde ein bisschen
traurig also das war ja früher ein
spannender austausch ort für tolle ideen
tolle gedanken im grunde genommen heute
diskutiert ja dann niemand mehr
miteinander jeder wirft nur irgendwie
beleidigungen oder eine meinung rein
aber die geht gar nicht mal so richtig
auf dem anderen ein sondern das
polarisieren sich einfach diese zwei
dinge und es entsteht ja überhaupt
keinen dialog wir drehen uns ja nur mehr
über uns selber es würde nirgendwo mehr
konsens gesucht und das wenn ich das
will und batterie bus lassen kann schon
ist die vielen fans die
heute in den sozialen medien sind die
die wirklich gefährlich sind das hat man
ja auch beim impfen erlebt was er alles
für verschwörungstheorien natürlich
roman wird könnt ihr nicht mehr
schwanger werden wenn man geimpft wird
und vieles vieles andere muss natürlich
sehen dass viele der jungen leute
eigentlich nur noch in diesem bereich
unterwegs sind also auch meine kann die
tageszeitung gelesen oder sonst
irgendein sondern sich nur über twitter
informieren oder über über dieses
sozialen medien vielleicht über in star
oder weiß was ich oder facebook also
sonst keine andere informationsquellen
mehr zulassen und natürlich denn diese
es auch glauben du erwähnt ist eben die
mangelnde konsensfindung die kann es ja
gar nicht geben weil ja nicht alle
miteinander diskutieren sondern die
jeweiligen babbels diskutieren
untereinander und kommen gar nicht
zusammen dann kann es auch gar keinen
konsens geben absolut aber billig in
einem podcast seitenwände wo ich auch
gerade zu gast sein durfte stelle mir
immer so eine ganz spannende frage und
zwar wie die welt aussehen in dem jahr
in dem du in rente geht 20
in den backen kultur in dem jahr seien
jetzt musst du meine prediction machen
um 20 51 wird die debattenkultur aus
also meine gäste sind fast alle extrem
optimistisch das finde ich sehr
sympathisch und ich bin auch optimist
deshalb wird zwei 1051 die
debattenkultur natürlich viel
friedlicher viel konsens orientierter
und mit einem viel besseren stil von
statten gehen